Scott Van Pelt a star anchor of the
mothership the midnight edition anchor
joining us on the program good morning
Scott how are you everybody's good it
was just you know Pauly had to brace me
for a tweet that you sent out a couple
of them where you yeah I mean you you
there's not much of Thanksgiving I
really care about but I do care about
pumpkin pie like I don't care about the
family getting together I mean you're
journalists I'll let you give us your
thesis on pumpkin pie and why you're so
down on pumpkin pie I don't like it and
I don't have to and you know here's the
thing the beauty of it is that there's a
very very passionate contingent that
loves pumpkin pie and to those people I
say I hope very much that you enjoy it
and you enjoy it with your family if
you're into that if you don't care about
your family I hope you just hunker down
in the corner with a big old caulking
pie and some whipped cream and you enjoy
you know being a bitter buy yourself
whatever you want to do with the pumpkin
pie is fine with me I just don't enjoy
it and the requests on Twitter was for
your most controversial take and I said
pumpkin pies garbage and then I began
discussing stuffing which if you put it
inside a turkey I find repugnant I feel
like those ingredients the best baked
and it did so they're not cooked inside
the carcass of a dead animal so that's
why I landed on that I don't I don't
enjoy the pumpkin pie I like other pies
better I like an apple pie like a cherry
pie like a pecan pie and so I leave that
happily and all the pumpkin pie people
by all means enjoy the pumpkin pie I
just I don't happen to enjoy it did this
hurt your brand Scott you know my brain
I don't concern myself with I care about
my I care about speaking my truth in I
got to speak my truth and if
authenticity and keeping it real in the
in these streets about pumpkin pike is
gonna hurt my brand that damn it hurt my
brand I'll be all right it's all about
street cred with you Scott and I respect
that
now when it comes to dessert pastry chef
is damn yeah you're damn right if you
couldn't
invite three ESPN anchors over for
Thanksgiving dinner
yep who would you invite current or
all-time no all right yeah all kind of
kids and I got butter you up me and I to
get back in your good graces and after
this pie Fiasco no I mean Leverett
because he's I've actually dined with
Neal and Thanksgiving it was fantastic
so Neal Everett would be number one
number two
Stamper Steven counties on an anchor
he's just he's my I don't know what he
is sort of a man about town he's our
fingers he's your fists he's you know
having been around he's just sort of a
goodtime charlie just makes sure
everybody's happy trying to tell how to
do this politically without making
people upset televisions John Buchi
grass he's been a good friend for many
years and that story goes back to once I
think boomer through it back to John
Buchi grass they said his bushy cross -
which boomer said they know who we mean
a so it's it's Neal average it's Buchi
it's Everett and it's who's that who's
the fourth who's our fourth
this is harder than it should be Steve
Levy ladies great surely he's awesome
he's another good time he'd be he'd be
the guy to adore restaurant I think levy
would be the night before Thanksgiving
guy who that's a good call because then
you go out and you have he has the spots
for everybody picked out yeah so maybe
it's a different person for Thanksgiving
I don't know I work by myself now I
don't see anybody so it's like I mean
but is that in your contract that you
don't have to work with any other anchor
Scott yeah I don't play well with others
is what it's mostly it's mostly that's
like keeps guy he bites people and he
doesn't play well with others and he
pisses everybody off about pies so keep
him there at midnight it's late
everyone's gone home and no one else has
to deal with him now they just you know
what they they just I was a test balloon
they said go out there and just after I
do what you want to do all see what
happens what is the show that you love
doing when this team loses ooh
[Music]
I think I think I mean when the Patriots
lose it's just it's not that I don't
celebrate it it's just it's unusual
because there are typically these
addendums written on the right I mean
when they lose and they got smacked by
Baltimore then it becomes was and I said
I bet I thought Poland was best team in
football and they appear to be but I
think when when they lose because it
happened so infrequently a you get you
get mumbling Bill Belichick where they
don't love it they made more plays than
us that's always the answer you get you
you and you it becomes these kind of
conversations about it at the end and it
never is
but I think the reactions to New England
and Mexico I mean it makes it more
interesting well I do wish you a great
Thanksgiving and I hope you're
surrounded by family and friend no I do
I do
I think you do mean it but do you
understand it applied thing like it's
not this it's not that serious
and then many people is research many
who agreed with me it's just this is PI
and I do I do want people to enjoy it I
just I don't like it and I'm not
encouraging I'm not encouraging people
to hit you with a pumpkin pie I am NOT
okay so I'll be they'll be foul because
the consistency and the smell yeah buddy
I don't want that on me no Jeremy and I
just I hope that you know I don't want
that to happen now Fritzi is getting a
pumpkin pie to the face in at the end of
the show but that's I mean you lost a
bet I mean it bets are back you got it
if you don't pay your bets you don't
have it you don't have your word if
you'll have your word what do you have
so that sounds like something he agreed
to win set when's the last time you
placed a bet on a game oh you mean about
a Stanford Steve Stanford Steve he helps
you
he sure is your go-to guy your middle
man they got people down there to take
years
have you you know what I always tell you
talk about bad beats on your show all
the time and as a former gambler you
know we always want to tell you when we
win it but it feels like now it's almost
like this badge of courage to reveal
your bad beat as opposed to you know
every gambler I would be around you'd
always say yeah you know I had them plus
the 7 you know and then you're going
really nobody ever tells you about when
they lose but now it feels like there's
a little bit more transparency
forthcoming I feel like if any I feel
like what we've done is we've made it
just it's it's shared this year in
misery makes it more palatable I think
is and also I mean it's it that everyone
has experienced it and and if you're
gonna bet you're gonna lose more than
your win in the end anyway so I think
all it is is just it it's just it's like
the miserable guide the corner bars you
know his girl just dumped him or
whatever he made you sort of bellied up
sit down and go yeah I remember this
this gal wherever it was it broke my
heart and that's all it is and it's
going to happen and this weekend God
knows there's so many opportunities and
windows would you know between the
football and all the you know tournament
basketball and pumpkin pie there's so
many ways to have a miserable things
giving Dan I mean you're surrounded by
it so be careful tread lightly watch
where you step thank you she's going Dan
you're the best good thanks buddy that's
Scott Van Pelt of the mothership there
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]